and they're finally starting to get a  cleanup underway here on a fatal crash  that happened at one o'clock this  morning almost six hours ago windmill in  Las Vegas Boulevard we have a live  picture showing you that East and  Westbound windmill are open they are  allowing North and southbound traffic a  little bit Northbound as you're getting  through trying to make that left turn to  get on to Windmill for Access which  actually becomes Blue Diamond get onto  the freeway south Ponders you've been  open for a little while otherwise you  can work your way if you're uh trying to  get out of the freeway you can go down  to Silverado Ranch watch out for a crash  at Silverado Ranch and Bermuda also